(upbeat electronic music)
- Hello and welcome.
My name is Charlotte Hill.
I'm a Ph.D. student here at UC Berkeley.
And I'm here with
professor of public policy
and political science Sarah Anzia
and the former governor of
Michigan Jennifer Granholm,
who's also a professor
here at UC Berkeley.
Welcome thanks for joining us.
- Thanks.
- Thank you for having us.
- So 2018 was an incredible year for women
at the ballot box.
- Woo hoo!
(chuckles)
- We saw an unprecedented
number of women getting
elected to the U.S. Congress.
And it seems like there's
something different this year,
compared to past elections.
But it's not totally clear,
from an outsider's perspective,
what it is that is different.
Is it just that more women were running?
Is it that women were
running campaigns that were
qualitatively different from campaigns
that had been run in the past?
Could either of you
shed some light on that?
Maybe Sarah.
- Sure.
Well I think the really big story
was the record numbers
of women running for
particularly U.S. House and
specifically, Democratic women.
I think prior to this year, the record for
Democratic women running for office,
running for U.S. House, was
something like 190 back in 2012.
And this past election, it was over 350
filed to become candidates.
It's a huge jump from the record.
And then on top of that,
they did really well.
Women won their primary.
Democratic women won their primaries
at higher rates than any other group.
And so what you had was a record number
of Democratic nominees who were women,
43 percent or something like that.
And I guess the other notable thing is,
this did not happen on
the Republican side.
The numbers of Republican women
running for House were pretty much.
They looked like they had before.
So this was definitely
just an amazing year
for Democratic women in
particular, running for office.
- There's another piece of information
which I think is such a great anecdote
about the enthusiasm on
the part of women to run.
'Cause normally, prior to this year,
you used to really have
to persuade women to run.
You had to ask them five times et cetera.
Emily's List, who of
course helps pro-choice
Democratic women, this past cycle.
So in a normal cycle, in the
cycle before this past one,
they had about 900 women
who had raised their hand
and had approached them
and said, "I wanna run."
In this cycle, so 900
last time, in this cycle,
42,000 women.
(exclaims)
Does that give you goosebumps or what?
So there is something
qualitatively different
about what has happened between
the last cycle and this one.
And it has caused more
women voters to step up.
And it's caused more
women to run for office.
So the question is, what is it?
And obviously, we got a big
answer in the White House
because it is largely Democratic women.
People are angry and feel
empowered to take our nation back,
feel like perhaps they have
a responsibility to do that.
And so that Women's March
and the millions of women who participated
in 600 marches across the country,
all of that sort of was the initial fuel.
And then after that, women felt like,
"Heck yes, this is my country.
"I'm not just going to sit back
"and allow others to
make decisions for me.
"I am gonna take a participatory role."
So that was super exciting,
I think a really important catalyst
in addition to probably some other things
that you probably have ideas on.
- Well I mean, this is just anecdotal.
But there were a number of accounts of
primary campaign ads also
that looked different
than they had in the past.
You had women running as women
rather than following
sort of the old playbook,
so campaign ads showing
women breastfeeding
or talking about sexual assault
or people bringing their kids along.
So that seemed, again
this is purely anecdotal,
but it seemed like a
shift this time around.
- Okay so in Michigan, this
is just one classic example.
The woman who ran for
Attorney General of Michigan,
her name was Dana Nessel.
She had a minute-long introductory ad,
and this is what her ad was basically.
Vote, this is not censored.
Vote for the one without the penis.
I'm not kidding you.
That was her ad.
And she won, like significantly.
She ran as a woman.
Obviously you have to run
as woman if you are a woman.
But your point about in previous times,
yeah you were told.
I was told, "Don't even show your children
"because people don't
wanna be thinking about
"whether you will be
capable of being in office."
But this time, totally authentic ads
that had women showing who they were,
women fighter pilots, women
with their families et cetera.
It was so refreshing and authentic.
And that I think is the
gift that this past cycle
has given to us, is this notion that
you can be imperfect and use some.
Not that being a woman is imperfect.
But you can use some of your challenges
as a way to have people relate to you,
obviously being a woman.
But I think of Stacey Abrams,
who ran for governor of Georgia.
She had some issues with
some finances in the past,
some loans et cetera.
And she used that as a way to say,
"I am not the only one.
"I am somebody who went to Yale et cetera,
"and I'm having problems."
So what is their average citizen having?
So all of that is to say
that authentic challenge and struggle
and laying it out there is
I think a real difference.
- So why do we think this matters,
to have women versus men holding office?
Clearly it matters for
descriptive representation,
for young women to grow up
seeing people who look
like them in office.
Are there other ways
that women legislators
govern differently or
legislate differently?
- Didn't you do some
research on that? (chuckles)
- Yeah well, and I think it
can easily be misrepresented.
I have an article I published a while back
with Chris Berry at
University of Chicago where
we show evidence that in Congress,
the female legislators
appear to outperform
the male legislators
in bringing money back
to their districts, in sponsoring
and cosponsoring bills.
They're doing more.
And there's actually
new work by Sarah Fulton
suggesting that women are also doing more
constituency service, more casework.
Now before you take that
and draw conclusions,
the explanation appears to be that
in the past, it has been more difficult
for women to have the same success
in getting elected to office.
And so to get the same vote share,
to get the same support from voters,
women on average had to be a bit better.
And so when you look at the
pool of people who are elected,
the women on average are
outperforming the men.
But in addition to that,
there is a lot of research
suggesting that female legislators
are more collaborative,
perhaps more bipartisan,
that they prioritize different issues.
They're pushing policies
supportive of women and families,
social welfare, civil
rights, health, education.
And there are some clear differences there
in terms of the policies they push.
- We certainly saw Hillary Clinton
champion early childhood education
child care for working parents
in her presidential campaign in 2016.
Can we expect to see some of those issues
staying at the top of
the policy priority list
in the 2020 presidential campaign?
- Oh I think so.
I think totally.
Women's issues have been sort of relegated
as the second tier of issues because
a woman is the one who bears children.
A woman is the one who is
primarily responsible in many cases.
However in an environment
where women are at the table
and insisting that these
are women's issues.
Yes but these are children's issues,
and children are male and female.
And this should be an issue for all of us.
And so I think what you're seeing,
for example even in California,
you have a male governor
who's pushing parental leave,
six month parental leave policies.
He's pushing universal preschool.
And that's awesome.
I think largely because Millennial men
and younger men who are coming up
understand the importance of
making sure that policy is inclusive
and helps the family move forward.
So those have historically
been women's issues.
Hopefully they are women.
They should be women and men's issues.
But I do think that just on
the process side, women are,
just anecdotally again.
I have found that women are
really quite collaborative.
So when I had the hardest
pieces of legislation
to push through, I had a Republican House
and a Republican Senate.
So I needed to work in a bipartisan way.
So whenever I had something
that was really tough,
there was a Democratic woman in the House
and a Republican woman in the Senate
that I would ask to work together on it.
And those two would do all
of the consultative work
that was needed for
the constituency groups
to make this happen et cetera.
They were by far and away the
most effective legislators,
Patty Birkholz, Representative Warren.
They were the ones who got
the hardest stuff through
because they could.
And they were not seen as
threatening for whatever reason.
- That's really interesting.
You mentioned Jennifer that
there had been a shift
after President Trump's
2016 election in the
mobilization and activation
of women at the grassroots
level, women voters.
Can you speak a little more about that?
How has that activism landscape changed?
- Oh it's awesome.
I mean look at all of these groups
that have been born since
Donald Trump was elected.
I guess that's the silver
lining for our democracy
is that he's really energized a huge
amount of participation.
And so whether it's Swing
Left or Sister District
or Indivisible, there's
just a plethora of groups,
a lot of them focused on women.
Here in the Bay area,
there's a group called Emerge
that really helps women to become elected.
And they have spread across the country.
And they, like Emily's
List, were seeing this huge
uptick in women who were
raising their hand to say,
(claps hands)
"I am in.
"I am interested in running
and saving my community
"in some way shape or form."
And it wasn't just Congress.
This happened up and down the ballot.
In Michigan, we had a
woman elected as governor,
a woman elected as Attorney General,
a woman elected as Secretary of State.
We took back too congressional
seats that were both women.
I mean it was really an all-female year
which was fantastic.
And it wasn't just
Michigan as an anecdote.
So I think that the President has been
an incredible motivator.
But ultimately on the
ground, it may be the spark
that got people to raise their hand.
But in real communities
across the country,
it really was health care.
And I think women are a trusted deliverer
of the message of the
importance of health care,
not that men aren't.
Men are as well.
But I think that women
embody that, whether it's.
It's not just reproductive freedom,
but that's one of the
aspects of health care
that I think people are energized about,
women are energized about.
So I think women took advantage of
both Trump in the White House
as well as Trump's expressed desire
to kill the Affordable Care Act,
to say, "No no no no no,
"We're gonna stop that.
"This is too important
for people on the ground."
- I mean I think one,
just the turnout in 2018--
- Yeah historic.
- just blew me away.
I give a lecture every year about.
I talk about the seesaw pattern
in midterm and presidential
election turnout.
In a typical midterm, it's
40 percent of eligible voters
participating typically.
It was something like
50, close to 50 percent.
This is a huge uptick.
It looked more like a
presidential election.
- Not quite presidential but close.
- Exactly and so somethin's.
That is really different.
I think compared to the midterms
in the last hundred years,
this just stands out
as a huge event.
- And I think what was striking about it
was the number, particularly of
suburban college-educated
women, who came out to
flip the House.
I mean really, they flipped the House.
Women of color, African
American women in particular,
are clearly such a strong
base for the Democrats
on making that.
But when you can add to that
by including women who
had perhaps even in 2016
voted for Donald Trump
and who had aligned with the Republicans
and who said, "Enough is enough.
"This is just too much to bear.
"I've got to get out and
help save my community."
That I think was a real
contributor to that.
- So that's really interesting.
Four in 10 women still identify
with the Republican party,
either by calling themselves Republicans
or saying they lean toward
the Republican party.
And yet we see certain issues that seem to
mobilize women on both sides,
regardless of their partisan slant.
So do you think that
there's an opportunity
for women to kinda come
together as a voting block,
as an issue-focused voting block
in 2020 and moving forward
and bypass some of the partisan politics?
- Maybe a little bit,
but I wouldn't be too optimistic there.
I mean so most Republican women
still wanted to confirm Judge Kavanaugh.
So their partisanship
is still a huge factor.
And the shifts we saw in
particularly white women
between 2016 and 2018 were significant.
So something like 53
percent of white women
voted for Donald Trump in 2016.
It looks like there was an increase
in the share of white
women voting for Democrats
for House this past election,
something like 49 percent
of Democrat white women.
But at the same time, that's not.
It's big because the numbers are big.
But partisanship is still
gonna be a huge divider there.
And I think that we can't
talk about women as a block
for that reason.
They're not a voting; they
don't vote as a block.
- I would say I have
a little more optimism
than you do, only because of the
unprecedented nature I
think of this presidency.
He's so sui generisant,
causes such reaction.
But particularly among Independents,
obviously that middle block is so huge.
And like 59 percent of the
Independents voted Democratic,
or maybe it was 56 percent.
But nonetheless, it was a big block.
And a lot of those women,
a lot of those were women, suburban women.
So I do think.
I mean historically, I'd
be curious about your
position on this Sarah.
Historically white women
have voted Republican.
And white women have seen, have often.
White Republican women have
aligned themselves behind
the patriarchy if you will,
taken cover by the patriarchy.
But I am seeing.
And perhaps it's just anecdotally,
and perhaps it's just 'cause
I'm in the mix on this.
But I am seeing so much alignment between
white women and women of color
as opposed to white women and white men.
So there seems to be a real push about,
we're all in this together,
and we've got to team up
to be able to make an impact.
- I mean I agree there's
definitely been a shift,
a perceptible shift.
How far it will go I am not quite sure.
I am not sure.
Polarization is at its peak.
And well we don't know.
But it's difficult to say how
much unification you can get
under the women umbrella
with that, with the degree of polarization
and partisanship we have now.
But we'll see.
We will see.
- So let's talk a little
bit about the media.
In the 2016 presidential election,
there was certainly a lot of talk about
Hillary Clinton being covered differently
by the media than Donald Trump
and even Bernie Sanders on the left.
And now moving into the
2020 presidential election,
which is already right around the corner,
we can expect to have
probably four at least
female Democratic
contenders for that race.
Should we expect that
media coverage will be
similar of those candidates
as it was of Hillary Clinton?
Do you think journalists
have learned anything?
- Right I mean the minute Elizabeth Warren
announced that she had formed
an exploratory committee
and she was getting in, you
saw a headline from Politico
saying, "Is She Facing
The Liability Factor
"That Hillary Clinton Faced?"
which is what you're alluding to.
I think the media has a role to play
in checking their biases at the door.
There's clearly about that.
I think women who are running know this.
It is clear that women,
that voters expect women
to be more likable,
whether that's fair or not.
Obviously it's not fair.
We never asked that about
the very unlikeable President
of the United States.
But anyway, we don't expect
the same thing of men.
But what I say to women who are in it.
Look it, you're gonna face biases.
It just is part of the deal.
So as Ann Richards said when
she was governor of Texas,
and it's alluding to the
whole thing you were saying
about women in state legislatures,
the old saw that women have to do.
Women can do everything that men can do.
Remember Ginger Rogers did
everything that Fred Astaire did.
She just did it backwards in high heels.
Women have to be twice as good
to be considered half as good.
And that's just it.
But (claps hands) here's
what I say to them (chuckles)
is that that's a fact.
But don't highlight the fact
that you think you are a victim
because people do not
want to elect a victim.
They want to elect a warrior.
And the only way we are
gonna eliminate those biases
is to get warriors in
office, at the table,
in those positions so that those biases
go away over time.
We're not gonna fix it in one election.
These women will have that bias.
But they cannot succumb to it.
- I think that the thing that
hasn't and will not change
is the need to go, to cover
what is gonna get clicks
and is gonna get readers.
- So true.
- And that is a constant.
At the same time, I think
that there's greater awareness
of the potential for
differential treatment
than perhaps there was a few years back.
And frankly, I think in
terms of the research,
it's really difficult to study
just because a lot of it's
so nuanced and subtle.
If you're trying to
create a measure of bias,
it's difficult
because a lot of it's hard to track.
And comparing Hillary Clinton
and Donald Trump in 2016,
okay it's difficult to
attribute anything that happened
to gender bias because
look, they're two people.
They're really unusual.
When people said her voice is shrill,
okay that's probably a gender thing.
But it's a difficult thing to study.
It's the sort of thing where
there are studies suggesting
there's no bias in the volume of coverage
and the content of coverage
if you look at men and women
congressional candidates.
At the same time you think,
uh maybe we're just not
measuring this right.
- And you know what?
There's the great, the democratization
of political discourse through Twitter
allows for entities to
be checked by the masses.
And there's so many young
people who are on there,
whose antennae are up and
are listening for this
and are checking the media all the time.
And I just have to say one thing
about this shrill voice thing
'cause you'll hear this again.
You even hear strains of it right now
in talking about Elizabeth Warren
when she went to Iowa et cetera.
This is the hardest
thing for women in office
because (deepens voice) we
don't have these deep voices.
And so our natural voice
is going to be higher.
And if you are making a forceful point,
the speech coaches will train
all of these women
candidates to try to lower
your voice rather than allow it
to get up to a higher register
because people are just not there yet.
- I would be in big trouble
(laughs) with the direction.
- (with deep voice) You would have to.
We all would.
I mean I certainly had to
check myself a lot on that.
- One thing that's really
interesting to me is that
we have some new members of the U.S. House
who are, particularly younger
women who have been elected,
like Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez,
who seem to be throwing
some of those rules--
- Love it.
- out the door
and saying, "I'm going
to be my authentic self,
"and if you don't it, so be it."
But people on the left
at least seem to like it.
So is there some sort of intersection
between age and gender
that is playing out here?
It seems like it.
- I think there totally is.
And I love these younger
women who are saying
basically screw you (chuckles)
to the political pundits
and all of the folks who have
historically brought women along.
And I think those who are in
the job of training women,
like the Emerges and the Emily's
List, they're understanding
that people are craving that authenticity.
That doesn't mean that you
can throw everything out
'cause there's certain sort of bounds
that you've got to operate in.
But I love the fact that
A.O.C. as she's called
uses social media in a savvier way
than almost anybody
out there in responding
and is fearless about it.
So that fearlessness I think
is a really important thing
that Millennials have given as a gift
to the political universe.
- So 2018 has been labeled
by political pundits
as the year of the woman.
And of course, it's not the first time
that this label has been put on a year.
1992 was the last time that
this label was applied.
And that was following
the Anita Hill hearings
and a handful of senators getting elected
in the wake of those hearings.
What are some of the
parallels that you see
between the early '90s and now,
and how do you think things have evolved
if at all, between then and now?
Let's start with Sarah.
- Sure well I mean there
are the obvious parallels,
a Supreme Court nominee
accused of sexual harassment,
sexual assault and the backlash to that.
At the same time, in '92
there was also of retirements,
congressional retirements, and
so this desire for outsiders.
And frankly, 'cause women are a minority,
they are viewed as outsiders.
- I totally agree.
- I think that that was part of it.
Things that are different though.
Well first of all, you ended up in '92
with a Democratic president
and a Democratic congress.
And that's definitely
not where we are now.
And polarization is sort of
the elephant in the room.
The divide between the political parties
is just nowhere near what it was in '92.
And I think that that has a major impact.
And also, Donald Trump is a phenomenon
that has no parallel in 1992.
I mean we're just in a
completely different world
with our current president.
Yeah so the real question is,
can we expect this
enthusiasm and this surge
in female candidacies to continue?
And after '92, we did not.
It wasn't a blip because
there was a steady increase over time
in the share of women running and elected.
And one nice difference
between today and '92 is that
I think it's seen as more legitimate
for women to hold office.
There are just a lot more women
who are getting elected and running.
But it remains to be
seen what's gonna happen.
Is the 2018 surge going to
continue into 2020, 2022?
I don't know.
It's too soon to tell.
You seem to think that--
- Yeah I mean
I think about it.
So in 1992, I think there were five women
who were elected in the Senate.
And that was the year of the woman,
five out of 100, woo-hoo.
And then, I think 20 years later in 2012,
there were 20 women elected in the Senate.
And that was seen as a huge breakthrough.
And so here we are in
2019, and we have 25 women.
And we're still not at 50.
So we've still got a long way to go.
I think this year of the
woman thing, (clicks tongue)
I think the difference really right now
is this notion of young
women who do not feel bound
by previous mores in terms of
how you operate politically.
I think that the young,
these Millennial women
and younger, the Gen Zs, I think.
They're called the Mil-Zs, the combination
of Millennial and Gen Z.
They are not havin' any of it.
They're not goin' back.
They are not havin' any of that.
So this push to authenticity
and to allowing people,
I think a lot of reality
TV has opened up the door
of allowing people just to be who they are
and to capitalize on struggles.
So there's a lot of women who were firsts,
who were elected as first
Muslim American woman,
first Native American women.
And they were unabashed about sharing
the challenges that happened
while and how they over,
I mean the story about overcoming
is the most important piece of that,
and how they championed
so that people see,
if you overcame that, I can
overcome my struggles too.
And being open and free to share,
I think that is a huge difference
and that women are by nature,
not by nature, by circumstance outsiders.
I think that point about
them being outsiders
is absolutely fundamental.
Why not try something else
'cause what we've got ain't workin'?
- Right and I think also
just the success of women
this particular midterm.
You have now a bunch of role models,
a bunch of people that
other women can look to
and say, "Oh maybe I could do that."
I think it does have the potential
to have a longer term impact
on the political ambition
gap between men and women.
- I totally agree, totally agree.
- So do you expect to see
the same number of women
running for office--
- More.
- More women.
- And the same or more
voter turnout among women?
- Yeah I totally think,
again partly propelled by
opposition to the President.
But I do think that you are
gonna see a woman on the ticket.
I firmly believe it.
I don't know if she'll be
in number one or number two,
president or vice-president.
But I think we will have
a woman on the ticket.
And that's gonna be exciting.
And I think you're gonna see more women
who are running for president,
who are legitimate serious contenders.
And that kind of brawling
is really healthy
from a democracy point of view.
- Sarah any predictions?
- I would love to be shown information
that would lead me to be optimistic.
I want to be.
(laughs)
I wanna be encouraged.
And I just look at the.
We don't know what will happen in 2020
and how long President
Trump will be around
to be this motivating force
and how permanent the impacts
are in the Republican party.
If not Donald Trump,
there could be another
Trump-like figure.
People are energized to participate
when their enemies are in office.
So when--
- Totally true.
- For better or worse, anger
is a very strong motivator.
So the question is, will that persist,
that motivation to--
- In 2020?
- In 2020 and beyond.
- Don't you think it will?
- Yes absolutely.
- Okay so--
- I'm just saying going forward--
- Beyond.
- Beyond yeah.
So the question being,
will we see the enthusiasm
and turnout dip at some
point in the future?
Is this a lasting change?
- Not in 2020.
But who knows into the future?
- One thing that was interesting
that I believe you
mentioned, Governor Granholm,
was the suite of resistance organizations
that have sprung up after 2016.
And I think of the four
or five that you listed,
all of them have a least
a female co-founder
- Totally--
- or are being led
100 percent by women.
So it seems like that could play a role
in maintaining enthusiasm and
turnout in the years ahead,
a new ecosystem of
grassroots organizations
championed by women.
- Yes.
- Can you speak to that?
- No no I think you put your finger on it.
I think women, not just in front of,
not just raising their
hand to say, "I'm running,"
but raising their hand to say,
"I am going to create an
ecosystem that ensures
"greater representation for
women across the board."
And so many of these, it's great.
They do have co-founders, many of them.
Some of them are just two women
who founded it and said, (claps hands)
"Enough is enough."
But the bottom line is,
the fact that women are
at the ground level,
building organization, building capacity,
in addition to running for office
and in addition to voting,
those three pieces of democracy are now,
you're seeing much greater representation.
And I think that will
bear fruit in the future.
- I think we should wrap it
up on that optimistic note.
Thank you so much speaking with us.
- You bet.
- Thank you.
- Thank you both.
(upbeat band music)